what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have a
special guest on the channel um the
sartorial shooter am I saying that right
yep
um you have over I can use my name now
by the way Jewel oh okay so you'd have
to use my name oh okay I wasn't sure I
wasn't sure
um so um you have over 180 000 followers
on Instagram
and you are known for being friends with
the Tates and you're here today to give
us some updates on the case and just all
around let us know how they are doing
never been introduced with reference to
my Instagram before it's not really
something our viewers is worthy of
mentioning it's it's I think I
accidentally have followers like I never
meant to be a followed person it's just
yeah fun with irritates and lifestyle
but yeah yeah no your content's very um
it's very interesting I'll see you guys
like on the boats and the Vlogs and
stuff
yeah we had fun we had fun and inshallah
we'll get back to having fun very soon
that's the plan so um tell me what
updates are you able to talk about on
the Tate case um I saw that he was just
released recently
I mean it released to house arrest yes
still detained though within his
residence
um okay so I can talk about it uh to a
limited extent I'm not you know an
official representative of Tate on his
friend he's my brother from another
mother it's not a formal thing I'm also
not a lawyer I'm far from a legal expert
so I can't talk about the intricacies of
the case but I can talk about Tate and
how he's doing um because I speak to him
every day he's in very good spirits
which is great so yeah they're in their
house they're focusing on the obvious
which is clearing their name they both
are very confident uh that their names
will be clear they know what they
haven't haven't done and they don't hold
any ill will towards any parties
involved in this either they know that
this has been a massive uh Injustice and
they're very confident that soon the
truth will win
and um
what was it I just can't even imagine
being imprisoned for three months for
something that that you didn't do how
are they still in good spirits after
that I would be so incredibly frustrated
yeah it's a tricky one there was
definite frustration there but one of
the things that the tits talk about is
the concept of an iron mind and that's
basically a mixture of stoicism a focus
every day on doing what you have to do
regardless of whether you feel like it
or not and just an unwavering logical
approach to life like emotions can be
controlled if you choose to control them
in a positive healthy way and that's
what the Tates can do so it was getting
frustrating definitely but they were
still training uh you know I know I was
communicating with Andrew now that he's
out I'm not sure about what Tristan was
doing but Andrew was reading the Quran
regularly which I think is great he
definitely leaned on his faith a lot to
help him which I think is is very
positive but I do know that it was
definitely a test for the brothers but
also let's be honest I've been through
plenty of tests it's not new for them
they grew up pretty rough you know South
Side Chicago Luton England these are not
highbrow places these guys grew up rough
and they're both professional fighters
Andrew's had over 80 fights so they're
not strangers to adversity and
everyone who knows them well wasn't that
worried about their mindset while
they're in prison I agree with you most
people would break them I mean I'm not
even sure how I would handle that sort
of thing but for them their iron mind is
real so they were sticking to the
routine they were focusing on what
matters staying disciplined in their
days even though they were very limited
for me the thing that bends my brain is
they literally went from the peak living
private jets Bugattis super Yachts
coming stuck in a Romanian prison now as
far as prisons go from what I understand
this you know it's not the Ritz it's
it's not a very high-end place to be
stuck so that uh discrepancy between
Ultra luxurious living then you know
really
harsh conditions for me I think it's
part of part of their path in life I
mean talk about a broad Human Experience
they've experienced the best of the best
and they've experienced arguably you
know some of the worst I think it's only
going to serve to make them more
more wise more powerful more insightful
imagine three months of forced
reflection time
I mean you're going to come out sharper
right if you're someone like Tate so
that's that's what's happened were they
in solitary confinement
I'm not sure on that
um I know they were together at one
point and then at one point they weren't
together but from what I understand you
know there was no mistreatment uh they
don't again they don't hold any ill will
against anyone involved if anything the
Tates understand that
false allegations are made in this world
and it's the role of of police forces
and governments to look into allegations
the Tates aren't angry at anybody
involved in terms of Romania they still
love Romania they always have they
really do love that country they love
its people what happened was there was
some individuals two of them
specifically who made very false
allegations of a very serious nature
that led to them being detained and
investigated still haven't been charged
and if they do they'll be they'll be
tried and then let out because these and
we can talk about it in specifics if you
want these claims are absolute lies and
it's it's obvious to anyone who's been
around the Tates I've been around the
Tates more than anyone hundreds and
hundreds of days over the last few years
I've lived in my house other than their
house I've been on the Yachts I've been
on the Jets these allegations are so far
from the truth that the truth will win
and they will be released
but I think the point I'm trying to make
here is they're not angry at any of the
parties involved because these things do
happen men who have money and status or
you don't even need to gender it people
who have money and Status will attract
certain types of toxic people who want
to take that money in that status and
are able to or comfortable making lies
and and stories in order to do that and
we have confirmation we've seen those
what's up chats we're the two main
complaints are saying hey you deserve an
Oscar hey let's go to Netflix we have on
the record proven about evidence that
these individuals were making up lives
so the truth will win it's just a matter
of time yeah and why when those came out
why wouldn't they not released
immediately when I saw that I was like
case done closed why do you think
they're still
I mean I think at the end of the day
it's a very complex situation and
you know allegations that are so severe
like that you know they need to be
looked into and I would hope that the
process of investigating those
allegations
is almost over there's CCTV footage
showing that the individuals in question
are happily coming and going from the
property that they're going shopping you
know they had phones on them the whole
time no one's Liberty was somehow
constrained there was no forcing of
anyone to do anything there's a lot of
evidence I believe it's it's escalatory
evidence it's a new word that I learned
from Myron from fresh and fit a lot of
evidence showing that the Tates are in
fact not guilty and all of that is in
the possession of of who it needs to be
in so it's now it's just a matter of
them analyzing that and coming to their
findings which will happen because the
truth is the truth Romania is an EU
country
um the Tates will be out soon inshallah
as we say in this part of the world
because these allegations are
categorically wrong and it's been
demonstrated that it's wrong the
Injustice has been demonstrated clearly
Tate often talks about fighting against
the Matrix do you think this was what
does that mean and do you think this was
a matrix attack
Okay cool so tight and I we differ a bit
on that um The Matrix being you know
them the the powers that the that want
to keep people in that sheep mode and I
think that definitely exists however
I I don't think that there's one sort of
overarching controlling body that sits
in a room and decides what to do with
you know people who speak against that
the programming The Narrative I think
there are a number of different matrixes
and a number of different entities out
there that want people to be a certain
way for example if you're a corporate
you'd like people to respond to your
marketing so you can sell them things
yeah so you want them to be acceptable
automatic messages if you're a
government
you know fighting age males who were
free thinking who were banded together
that's that's you know a threat to to
power so you'd like men to be more
effeminate and easier to control so I
think there are many different agendas
often competing from the the different
entities that will power in this world
um so I don't think there's one cohesive
Matrix personally but was this an attack
by the powers that be in terms of
wanting to silence Andrew in his message
I don't think we'll ever know I don't
think we'll ever have a conclusive
answer on that I do know that this was
initiated by two individuals making
clearly easily debunked incorrect claims
about the Tates and I do know that there
are a lot of people of power in the west
who would like the taste to shut up I
mean that's evident whether there's
correlational causation uh I'm not sure
really everyone how would we ever know
really yeah really everyone seemed very
um in the west very pleasant and very
supportive of the Tates
that's true it's not like the UK is
spending billions of dollars to try and
shut him up in the schools it's
interesting looking into that I've
noticed that and you might already be
aware of this schools are a real
Battleground for ideology like if if you
and I are exposed to certain types of
ideology for example
um certain types of sexual degeneracy uh
it's not going to impact us whereas you
get that in front of kids you normalize
certain agendas you know through Netflix
or through you know become making it a
societal Norm when kids are involved
they're a lot more susceptible so it
doesn't surprise me that in schools a
lot of efforts are being put into
counter Tate's narrative when Tate is
telling young men and and young women as
well Traditional Values are okay you
know you should be self-reliant you've
got to watch out for the programming to
make you a feminine and a sheep you
should be competitive discipline all
these things I'm not surprised that the
schools are a real Battleground for what
type of ideology is going into the minds
of the youth and why do you think that
Tate is so inflammatory why do you think
it's having this reaction I mean I've
done Street interviews and the women get
so angry when you just say his name he's
a misogynist he's a sexist he's
um I don't I can't use this word on
YouTube but a Grapist and it's like why
are they so angry about a man just
speaking on the internet
yeah I think it's it's an interesting
one look I'm I'm a father and a very
caring father I have a daughter I have
very healthy relationships in my life so
I'm very Pro uh women's safety I'm a
security professional I've trained
literally hundreds of women in in
security personal security self-defense
and so on so I'm very pro-women being
safe in this world as well and I can
understand why there's passion there but
it's completely
um misinformed negative responses to
Tate if you were to watch Tate's long
form uh content not just the sound bites
that have been pushed out you'll see is
actually a very positive
influence in that 90 plus percent of
what he puts out 96 97 the vast majority
of take content doesn't even talk about
women it talks about you know
self-accountability about discipline
about respecting family respecting Faith
it's incredibly positive in a world
where there are no masculine role models
for the Youth out there young men today
their Heroes have been taken away who
are they to look to for that masculine
old-school traditional motivation
so the vast majority of Tates content is
positive however I'd say the vast
majority of people especially the haters
they haven't watched the long form stuff
and if anyone had actually spent time
around him you'll notice all of his
inner circle saying the same thing we
know Andrew we've seen him he's polite
with every waiter or waitress he meets
he's polite with every woman that he
meets to try and say that he's because
of the character that he used online to
build Fame and let's face it it worked
most most Googled man of all time you
know he's an Entertainer that's the one
thing like that people people will take
things that he's saying and like
tongue-in-cheek and try to paint it as
serious in a clip it's pretty wild yeah
and if we're going to do that if we're
going to take everything literally then
every gangster rapper needs to go to
jail right now you know shooting people
every WWF wrestler you know I'm gonna
find you then they'll need to go to jail
it's ridiculous so the one claim that I
do see
coming from a lot of media houses I love
to talk about the media at one point is
oh yes but a lot of young men can
misconstrue Andrew's words and take them
literally I think young men nowadays
know when Andrew Tate's being satirical
I think that's a bit patronizing to
think that young men can't tell when
he's being playing a character but also
let's say out of every one young man who
took one of Tate's messages out of
context and it's negatively impacted his
behavior there would be hundreds if not
thousands of young men who've been
positively impacted by Tate's real
message now we can't quantify or measure
that but again the vast majority of
Tates content is overwhelmingly positive
that's why it's popular he's not popular
because he said some bad things you know
using a comedic character about women
he's popular because the message he puts
out is incredibly powerful and it's
lacking in today's world and young men
especially really resonate with them it
adds value to their life it makes them
more discipline makes them more you know
getting back in the gym the amount of
times Andrew has shown me because he's
proud about it messages from young men
who said I had a gun in my mouth I found
you and now I'm in the gym I'm
reconnected with my father who I had a
bad relationship with Tate has had such
a positive impact on so many people's
lives one other thing if you walk around
with Tate as I do often people are
coming up to him on all that all the
time you know Hustler's university has
enabled me to buy a car for my mum you
know I've quit my job thanks to you I'm
motivated thanks to you and this new one
he has the real world has led to this
this people are coming up saying that
his message and his products have
positively impacted their lives all the
time so people out there trying to say
that he's somehow a negative influence
they just haven't done their research
they haven't looked into it deeply
enough no that's that's happened to me a
couple times too when I've done the
street interviews about Tate it's like
you'll get the angry feminists that
usually have just seen Clips never seen
as long form content
um and then you'll get the young man
that are basically saying that he's
changed their life that they started
working out because of him making more
money because of him pursuing women
because of him and it's like it's always
the people that that don't really know
his content that are getting angry
um so this is a actually happened to me
recently um what do you think the impact
has been of short form content
with Tate and do you think that has
clouded his message at all due to
reaction channels and feminist agenda
um really just sitting on his streams
looking for something they can take out
of context and paint him as a bad guy
yeah definitely I think it's a definite
risk in in today's day and age when you
know Tick Tock is short and people's
attention spans to 0.3 of a second I
think it's very difficult to ever
encourage people to to look into things
properly now we're living a world where
there's so much stimulus we're pulling
so many different directions especially
the youth
they don't have that sort of stop and
think and really analyze one one stream
of thought it's always moving around
constant constantly stimulated so I
don't know how to stop it and I think
it's a reality that Tate is now very
aware of uh I don't think he he could
even comprehend how viral some of that
negative negatively sound-bited content
could go and now when you see tape come
out me is is a smart guy he's going to
be very specific about what he says and
how he says it so that those haters out
there can't selectively sound bite and
and paint what he says in a negative way
one thing I'd like to talk about the way
the media is ignoring the positivity of
his message and so-called journalists
aren't even investigating fair enough
people on the street who are hate us
they have no responsibility to look into
Tate in in terms of the long-form
content but journalists to adhere to
some form of journalistic Integrity or
professionalism surely they could look
at his long-form content the best
example being the old um the machete
comment now that where he says you know
bang out the machete grab her and so on
that was put out in short form by
so-called credible media houses saying
look he's advocating for violence
against women which of course isn't in
the long-form video he's talking about
if a woman was to pick up one of the
machetes in his house and come at him
because he was cheating or because
they're having an argument how heard he
would respond wow the machete he'd grab
her he was talking in a self-defense
um context but they completely cut that
out and they just showed it as if he
would put a machete in a woman's face
journalists who are from large media
houses did this it's absolutely
disgusting it's either a very clear
agenda against hate or journalists
nowadays have very poor investigative
skills and no ethics it was it was
incredible to see it in real time would
you guys ever pursue legal action
against some of the journalists that are
clearly intending to take him out of
contacts like that
I'm not sure I'm not reading on on
Tate's legal matters um but from what I
can see Tate's main focus now is
obviously clearing his name and then
using this huge influence he has to come
out and put forward a positive message
he understands that to a certain extent
the Youth of today follow his words and
so by extension he understands he has a
very strong duty to bring about positive
changes to their lives Tate's never
listed any crypto coin he's he's never
done any pump and dump like a lot of
other influences he hasn't signed up for
like the um you know various streams
where you get paid by gambling there's a
lot of it now a lot of influencers
getting paid a lot of money to go and do
that he said no to all of that stuff
because he is very committed to having a
positive impact on the lives of his
followers so when he comes out that'll
be his full Focus
um so you sent me I'm going to pull
these up really quick the tenants of
Tate could you tell me a little bit more
about those
yeah definitely so again all these
journalists out there who want to say
that Tate's somehow a nasty person Tate
has written his philosophy and his
guidance for Life clearly and it's
easily accessible you can find on his
website you can Google tenants of Tate
there's
41 different points that clearly outline
what Tate stands for it's very
pro-traditional values it's
pro-masculine accountability it's a pro
as a man understanding that you need to
build yourself in every area of life to
provide for your family you know your
loved ones to be a positive impact on
society so all these journalists who
somehow want to say that Tate stands for
negative
negative messages have a look at the
tenants of tight that is him writing his
clear no filtered philosophy on life and
it's overwhelmingly positive but again
it talks against the narrative doesn't
it it wants men to be masculine and
wants women to be caring and feminine
it's it's against the modern day
depravity that we have pushed on us why
do you think that is like I cannot think
for the life of me why we would not want
masculine men and feminine women like
why is there such an anger and an
animosity towards Traditional Values
I've experienced that myself because I
adhere to Traditional Values very
careful very very thoroughly one the
first point I'd like to make is I think
the one question I always ask people who
have you know specific belief systems
how those belief systems working out for
you if you believe that you can identify
as anything
how is that working out for you like are
you happy are you are you a fulfilled
person what I see again and again the
most because let's face it the dynamic
in your house is going to set the tone
for for your life so relationships are
very important the happiest people I
know you know from lived experience are
in relationships where they adhere to
Traditional Values the men do what men
have traditionally done the women do
what women are traditionally done and
everyone's everyone prospers everyone's
happy so yeah the push against that
I think it's because it's just a matter
of control again masculine men who are
free thinking who have a solid
relationship with God through their
chosen Faith who have a strong family
unit they're not going to be as easily
LED as a feminate unfit unhappy men the
more unhappy you are the more
susceptible you are to to marketing
messages you know go and buy the iPhone
that matches your personality so you
think it's it's yeah so you think it's
about control because 100 oh because
these journalists have more control if
they can paint you a certain way and
just take these clips out of context and
then they can control The public's
opinion of you and they can also watch
all the narrative a bit too
yeah I think journalists want what will
get them clicks and take saying
something positive won't get nearly as
many clicks as take and something
negative but I think if you look at it
from the context of Western governments
it's clear to me that they don't want
men to be masculine because masculine
men are hard to control you want a man
who is essentially effeminate uh scared
of higher authority ideally absolutely
controlled by his wife you know as Tate
once said I can't go out and protest
have to be home by nine or the wife will
be angry married men in the west often
self-regulating citizens because of that
so the more effeminate you can make men
you know the the more you can Trash
Traditional Values the easier they they
are to control that's from a government
standpoint and from a commercial
standpoint again the more unhappy you
are as a person the more easily LED you
are the more sheepish you are the more
susceptible you are to marketing
messages the more you're going to go and
buy the things they tell you to buy so I
think both governments and corporates
benefit from men particularly being she
oh but if they're masculine and they
follow their own path and they have
values then all these corporations can't
control that and that's why corporations
governments people and that is why
they're so angry because they're losing
control
um that's my view definitely wow let's
face it if you if you are the elites of
the world there's a lot more of the
masses than there are of the elites you
know that's that's a simple mathematical
fact
I think you'd always be conscious of the
fact that you want the people to stay
controllable
because if again if everyone's
questioning their role in life because
everyone's questioning what they're told
that's a risk and Tate
speaks to that Tate empowers the
individual Tate speaks against the
programming that everyone should just be
obedient cheap and do whatever they're
told and so I think to a certain extent
Tate's message could be viewed as
somewhat of a threat in terms of how
easily controlled the masses are the
flip side is though Tate and Tate's
message is building hard-working young
men is building women who think you know
what it's okay for me to want a man to
protect and provide and I'm going to
look after him there's nothing wrong
with having that that polarity that yin
and yang that harmonious house as
opposed to everyone trying to compete
with each other so yes I think some
people view text messages as a threat
but the reality is it's overwhelmingly
positive and if you've spent time around
the man like I have you can't help but
be reminded constantly of how much of a
positive impact he's had on on the
hundreds and hundreds of fans I've seen
walk up to him and say those exact words
no I've been
um since the since I interviewed him
there's been so many reporters trying to
get me to like say he did something
crazy or try to like pull something and
I'm like no he was polite he was very
nice like nothing negative that's the
thing just to speak to that just just
quickly if I may um I'm not an objective
uh source of information when it comes
to Tate I'm strongly protect I view him
as a brother you know but I am credible
you know I've held in the past very
senior corporate positions
um a long time ago I held high-level top
secret clearances with my previous lines
of work I'm I'm professionally trained
in assessing people I'm a trained
investigator I've been working as an
investigator for over a decade the idea
that he's somehow some nasty
person capable of all these terrible
things is complete nonsense I would have
seen that I I he's lived in my house for
months on end I've been with him on the
Yachts the Jets I've seen it all he's a
good man who treats people well and I'm
a credible source of of assessing that
and I've been around him for hundreds of
days so with respect all these
journalists and these Twitter
independent journalist experts none of
them are very capable of their jobs
because their read on Tate is is the
opposite of who he actually is as a man
yeah and how could you have such a
strong opinion on someone if you had
never spent time with them or met them
that's pretty amazing because I first I
first started going public on some
Twitter spaces I'm not a I'm not I'm not
interested in clout and again I'm a
security professional it's not that
useful for people to recognize me on the
street however Tate is my brother and
it's my responsibility to speak up for
him I had to jump onto some of these
Twitter spaces before my Twitter got
mute but that's a you know cancellation
culture that's a different discussion
because people were speaking with
authority about Tate having never met
him all these people were experts on the
psychology of Andrew Tate having never
been in the same room as him so I had to
speak up and I've been doxed you know
I've had threats made against me people
have doxed my home address thankfully
I'm I'm pretty well positioned to deal
with threats you know a specific set of
skills one of a long career but if I
wasn't capable of dealing with these
threats it'd be pretty serious I've had
a lot of people come after me because
I'm friends with Andrew Tate I don't
care they can keep coming I'm going to
speak up for my brother but the backlash
against everyone just representing the
truth and saying no actually I know Tate
I've been around him and he's a good man
it's been intense have you had people
come after you because you're you know
effectively supporting Tate or not
speaking against Taylor yeah um no
people don't I mean they're always
fishing like they're trying to make it
seem like when I met him maybe he tried
to like traffic you know or do something
crazy and I'm like no he came he did the
interview it was fun we laughed like
that was it
the idea that someone owns a Bugatti and
and 30 other cars flies private it's on
super jets but somehow has the time and
energy to traffic a woman for a very
small amount of money it's it's it's
illogical it's it's farcical it's
nonsense but no one's applying any logic
here because they want to take paint is
a bad guy because he speaks against the
narrative
um
admit that he did the cam work stuff
right like even with that I I feel like
women um they really don't give us
enough like credit like if you choose to
do that that's your choice
like nobody put a gun to your head and
made you do cam work like I just I was
exactly I was telling my dad about this
I'm like Dad would you feel bad for me
if I lived in a mansion and did Cam work
and went shopping and then later I cried
wolf it's just like
did use
um the managing of Cam and only fans to
build money initially but also he came
from pretty like they were hungry at
certain points in their life they came
from very poor levels and they were
hustling they were doing whatever they
had to do to get ahead what it's not
illegal to run only fans agencies or run
cam agencies and this whole thing's
saying are about lover boy technique
this and that it's not illegal to go
into a relationship with a woman and
then work together in an industry where
both people are getting paid and both
people can walk away at any point that's
the thing with Tate and I've seen this
the second a woman disrespects him or
disagrees or decides they're not going
to work together in a harmonious way
he'll have nothing to do with it his
challenge is pushing women out the door
not trying to keep them inside so again
it's all completely illogical and and
yes I don't view cam work or only fans
work as as
as clean it's haramas per my beliefs but
he hasn't broken any laws here and the
idea that somehow he's some terrible guy
how do you produce footage for these
sorts of things you use a phone that you
have in your hand that can also call the
police like if you're in trouble the
idea that you don't have the ability to
make that call hang on this is wrong I'm
going to make a phone call uh how
patronizing is that towards women and
their ability to make healthy decisions
about their own lives the whole thing's
ridiculous yeah what do you think of the
people that say the women were just
secretly scared that you guys would hold
them back and not let them leave
what do you what do you think about that
well first of all from what I understand
this I mean we can see on the on the
CCTV footage they're free to come and go
one of one of the recent CCTV footage
that came out they were unpacking the
bags from luxury shopping again if
you're on the Jets and the Yachts living
in a mansion and you know unpacking a
car from Gucci and LV traffic me sign me
up that's what I was thinking when I saw
it but Jokes Aside like it's actually
disgusting to make these allegations
because real human trafficking does
exist and when you try and make these
allegations when you have women who are
clearly not being trafficked it Waters
down all of the real crimes that are
happening out there so the whole thing's
incredibly unethical it's just it's it's
a lot of mistakes have been made a lot
of poor analysis has been applied and
and the truth will win very soon it's
been long enough you know what is it
we're over a year now where they've been
investigated and there's nothing to
charge them they are going to win they
are going to get out and when the name
is cleared they're just going to be more
focused on being positive more
influential and and bringing about more
of a positive impact on the world I'm
very excited about their proper please
be a very positive day how common do you
think it is for men to be falsely
accused
I'm not sure for me I think if you're
allowing certain and it doesn't even
need to be gendered if you're allowing
certain levels of people into your into
your life you know low class taker toxic
people then the risk will increase very
much so whereas if you're very careful
with who you let into your circle which
of course the Tates are going to be now
for some of these times that they were
apparently trafficking women they
weren't even in the house
there are a bunch of women having
parties in the house they weren't even
dare I think numerous times they weren't
even in the country so you need to be
very careful about who you even let into
your house even if you're not there
nowadays so this is a you know very
clear lesson learned from them uh for
them or for any any man um so I'm not I
can't speak to how often uh false claims
are made against men because that's a
risk I've mitigated in my life I'm very
careful about who I bring into my life
um and I think every every man out there
should be because the risk is very real
if an individual can make a claim
against you because oh I feel a bit
pissed off because of a breakup or
whatever that can then result in you
being investigated and detained you need
to be very careful who you let into your
life that that's that's the State of
Affairs we've come to in today's world
well you guys
um look into pressing charges against
the women that made the false
accusations
I'm not sure again I'm not ready on
legal matters I mean it's mate I'm not
you know not a legal professional from
what I understand in terms of his
sentiment he doesn't hold any ill will
against anyone he just wants us to you
know he wants the investigation to be
concluded he wants the truth to come out
and so he can clear his name and get
back to being a positive impact on the
world that's the main focus
I want to read some of the negativity
that he spews into the world
the horrible so
um guys I was sent the tenants of Tate
and you said these are on his website
these are basically the principles
um that he lives by so I'm just going to
go through them so
a call to be responsible disciplined
respectful and a positive contributor to
your friends family and Society
one that sounds terrible yeah horrible
horrible one I believe that men have the
Divine imperative to become as capable
powerful and competent as possible in
this life
two I reserve the right to hold my own
beliefs and practice them as I see fit
and I allow all other people the same
right to believe and act as they wish
three I prefer loving rewarding
consensual relationships with beautiful
positive and virtuous women
I believe that men and women are
different and that each has its own
unique and important strengths and
abilities
we can't say that anymore that could get
us both canceled
I believe that men have a sacred duty to
protect and provide for the important
people in their life I believe men have
the sacred duty to protect the innocence
and sanctity of their children and
reserve the right and responsibility to
raise their children as they see best to
ensure long-term happiness and success I
believe that men have the sacred duty to
raise strong capable and honorable Sons
I believe that men have the sacred duty
to raise kind feminine and virtuous
daughters
I utterly disprove of violence within
romantic and family relationships they
did not cover that so can I just can I
speak to that just quickly Tate is so
calm and has such emotional control that
when he was being canceled you know
losing Banks losing social media losing
everything his emotions didn't change
his so his emotions are so under control
that even in jail for something he
didn't do for months he stayed
level-headed the idea that he's somehow
some crazy guy who was violent to
people's absolute nonsense if you're
around Tate I've never once seen him
angry again I've been around this guy
very closely for five years he is so
emotionally controlled so the idea that
he's somehow losing is cool and hurting
people that is the exact opposite of who
he is as a man sorry to interrupt but
it's an important point no um I think it
isn't like even when he was on the panel
with me
um I mean we had two of the craziest
guests like ever we've ever had on the
show and a lot of guys would lose their
cool with how much they're interrupting
him and like going at him but he was
perfectly calm
yeah
um 10 I support good and honors
conversations and I will obey obey
oh wait I support good and honest
governments and I will obey only their
laws I prefer to conduct business
dealings with trusted embedded Brothers
I believe that a man has a sacred duty
to hold true to his word and do exactly
what he says he will do
I believe that a man's life is difficult
and that he has the sacred duty to
become strong to handle such difficulty
um I believe men are personally
responsible for their actions and for
the results that they achieve in their
lives I've got to speak to that yeah
that's an important one yeah whenever
you whenever you hear one you want to
speak on it cool thank you so tight's
whole thing is women are not to blame if
there's a poor relationship that's on
you as a man you know if you're
associating with low level I mean it
doesn't even need to be gendered one of
the clear pieces of advice that Tate's
giving out to the world is be careful
you know get rid of toxic people cut out
toxic habits cut out toxic uh social
interactions so the idea that uh take
this somehow hating on women or he it
takes the guy saying to men hey if you
have issues with women you need to
become better take this calling for
personal accountability so if anything I
think you know the feminists and the
haters should be happy because the world
needs more people like that saying look
you know to the young men of today if
you can't find a good relationship
that's on you be a better man as opposed
to oh women are no good nowadays it's
all very positive
thanks man
uh sorry I forgot which one I was on I
believe number 15. oh thank you
I believe in emotional control and the
vital need to become disciplined and
professional in all things
I believe that men have the sacred duty
to approach everything in life from a
position of strength
I believe all men have the duty to
become I believe that all men have the
sacred duty to become men of upright and
virtuous character and live above all
possible reproach I believe it is
incumbent incumbent upon me to
ruthlessly identify my own weaknesses
and limitations and I eagerly work to
overcome them and become more capable in
all Realms yeah let me talk to that one
if I could so I've been around very high
profile people for some time with my
line of work you know Tate is the
hardest worker I've ever met he will not
eat all day until he's achieved a
certain amount whether it's learning or
or making money or conquest or building
that guy is so driven to be the best
version of himself every day he's
actually a very positive role model
because he walks the walk he doesn't
just talk that man every day is pushing
to become as capable as he can in every
realm of life that's a fantastic role
model for young men thanks
19. sorry sorry I was like okay
I I seek to improve my personal freedom
to act to think act and live true to my
masculine imperative in all ways I
believe each man has a sacred duty to
mold his physical body into the
strongest most resilient and most
capable version of itself possible
I believe that men have the sacred duty
to rigorously train themselves both
physically and mentally every day
I believe that I have the sacred duty to
only eat the highest quality foods to
possible to maintain my health vitality
and masculine
the reality of virility
I reserve the right to protect the
sanctity of my bloodstream and make my
own decisions about my medical care and
procedures I don't think you can say
that today either can you you know we're
at risk of getting canceled here yeah
this sounds so this is all horrible
terrible horrible today hearing these
sorts of messages
and the journalists will clip this and
say pearls against Tate
sure what's up that's what they do
you'll say a joke and and then they'll
clip it and be like she's a hundred
percent serious I'm like no absolutely
nonsense and we haven't even had deep
fake be perfected yet what happens when
that comes in and you'll never know
whether it's a real person or it's you
know like that the Battle For Truth in
today's day and age it's a tricky one it
really is oh I didn't even think about
that yeah because they could make a
video of me saying something I didn't
say or of Tate saying something I didn't
say it's coming it's definitely coming
and it could go so viral that no one
would even know the difference
yeah for sure it's coming
um
24 okay okay I affirm the importance of
endlessly improving my mental faculties
through diligent work study and practice
I believe in acquiring wealth and
abundance in order to improve my life
and do good for those I care about
they're such giving people like a few
videos have gone out of them giving
money randomly or supporting Charities
or you know driving the Ukraine border
with clothes they do this stuff all the
time that's part of the reason why I
felt the need to speak up the Tates are
two of the most giving people I know
they have built wealth to look after
their people they say it all the time I
look after my people and they really
live by that they're taking care of so
many uh people so many families they've
retired their parents these are good
giving virtuous men the haters who are
coming after them typically they're so
broke they can't even take care of
themselves so so who would you rather
emulate some negative person who doesn't
add any value to the world apart from
writing negative tweets on on online or
two young men have built themselves up
from literal bottom of the rung you know
in terms of money to top of the rung in
terms of money and are able to look
after the people in a so very giving and
most of these reaction channels all they
do is criticize everyone they don't
stand for anything they don't believe in
anything all they want to do is
criticize the people that are actually
doing things and that's what's
irritating is you get these like
streamers in their rooms they don't do
anything with their lives and then
they're mad at the guys that are
actually doing things and it's just like
how are these streamers famous no
they're like they're like out of shape
losers sorry but it's just like I know I
know some of them like some of them even
like they
they think there are somehow credible
source to prove you know to give input
on other people's lives when their own
lives are a mess like I know of a
certain person who's whose wife
routinely sleeps with other men and this
person allows that but this person
thinks they're in a position to judge
the Tates I'm sorry if you don't even
respect yourself enough
to to not allow the woman who's in your
bed to go and be with a bunch of other
men you don't have the right to pass
opinion on people who are living in a
productive high output Traditional
Values way it's just not real I I mean
look I'm staying the internet nowadays
when you have clearly
like absolute losers who are failing in
life in terms of physicality Brotherhood
relationships money everything somehow
thinking they have the right to pass
judgment on people who are living high
output high value add to society lives I
really can't get mad around that I mean
if you can educate me no no and it's so
obvious out of jealousy it's so obvious
that it's out of jealousy because I mean
Ted's living in a way that these guys
couldn't dream of you're telling me this
man is in an open relationship he can't
even fathom a world where you know 10
women would want to be faithful to only
him
yeah you just can't comprehend it so
he's angry at it well and his his
response is oh the women must have been
coerced oh there's um they must have
been misleading the women the women
didn't actually know because he can't he
can't even fathom a world where women
would want to be faithful to a guy they
have to share because he hasn't figured
it out he just yeah it's not real in his
reality he can't see his real so he has
to say it's fake and negative as a cope
I've seen the women in the Tates orbit
they are fulfilled they are looked after
that you know there's Traditional Values
in place they are every need they have
is met so and they're most certainly not
sleeping with a bunch of random men
even to the Youth of today I hope that
look at the credibility of the person
who's giving analysis you know examine
credibility of the source it's a very
simple concept from those who have
conducted investigations these the blue
head Brigade are not credible sources to
give advice or analysis on anything
because they can't even sort out their
own lives well and you really see The
credibility of a journal you know it's
one thing everyone has their their spin
on the world right like nobody is
objective I hate this idea of objective
journalism no I'm not objective you're
not objective everyone has their view on
the world based on their world view and
based on how they were raised okay so
this objective journalism so it's one
thing to look at a situation and get the
facts wrong that's half that's happened
to me you know my first video watching
Tate I didn't really like him I saw the
cheating party and I was like what does
this mean that was the first video I saw
of his and I I view I don't know fun
night fun night yeah yeah look at this
was like years ago so I didn't really
know him and my first interaction was
like I was like why would he do that
that's so rude you know and I I was
still up on my channel it's old but it's
um and that was my first interaction but
it's like it the what you see where you
see The credibility of a journalist is
do they change their opinion with new
information
or do they do they continue to have the
same opinion regardless of the facts and
it's really unfortunate to see a lot of
these you know reaction channels that
are that are about objective journalism
apparently
um not change their opinion when facts
come out like these women going out
luxury shopping
yeah exactly again sign me up you know
yeah and that's I think today I'm like
is there room in this I'm just kidding
yeah exactly why yes I'm like if you had
applications where other it would be
like oh jam-packed the website would go
down pretty much traffic yeah but
journalists nowadays and this is why you
know the people don't trust the big
media houses anymore they're not looking
to put forward facts to your point I
really like the way you said that they
won't change their opinions their party
line based on your information they're
just pushing an agenda so then no one's
no one's really I think the the BBC's
The cnns they're going to continue to
decline in credibility because they just
can't help themselves they're not there
for truth anymore they're there to push
a narrative that they've been told to
push they're sheep themselves
yeah and I'm I'm a big believer and the
truth always comes out so people can
make someone look a certain way or paint
a certain way in the short term and
maybe spin a narrative but in the long
term like
you just can't hide it because
apparently there's too many people that
interact with a certain it doesn't even
have to be Tate but anyone where their
character in the long term is gonna is
Gonna Come Out you can't paint someone
as a racist a sexist and a homophobe
forever because after long enough you're
gonna have enough people that vouch for
their character like where where are all
the people that have been around Tate
that have had such a horrible experience
outside of the women that are falsely
accusing him
yeah for real exactly 100 very well said
fully agreed
um okay I think we're on 25
um I believe in acquiring wealth and
abundance in order to improve my life
and do good for those I care about I
believe in the merits of healthy
competition and constantly encouraging
all men to seek out competition to
improve themselves I believe that
masculine Brotherhood is essential to
men's mental health happiness and
success and I relentlessly encourage men
to meet together train together and work
together I think yeah okay go ahead I'm
sorry off to you please no I think
that's so true I can't even there's so
many kids that are from like like um
just two kids in the family or one kid
in the family where it's like a boy and
a girl and they don't have brothers and
I see how good it is for my because I'm
one of ten so I see how good it is for
my brothers yeah yeah I know crazy
you're right but I see how good it is
for my brothers to like have men around
them that they can do stuff with and I
just can't even imagine like it's no
wonder that men are so feminized today
because they don't have brothers to like
do things with because of the lack of
children
yeah and the lack of that healthy
competition and everything so
Brotherhood is something I often talk
about and I like to say that after
Health Brotherhood is one of the most
important forms of wealth and that's why
I'm so open and positive about the War
Room Tate has created a community of men
it's thousands of men all around the
world all who have similar belief
systems who follow the tenets of Tate in
terms of their approach to life who are
working to become the best versions of
themselves financially health-wise
relationship-wise everything he's built
this incredibly powerful organization
where the positive impact inside and
I'll say it myself my life has greatly
improved since I joined the war room and
we have thousands of men saying the same
thing you know that they're even the way
they're parenting their kids they become
more attentive more loving you know
family members their finances have
improved their Fitness is up Tate has
built a global community of men based on
this concept of Brotherhood and of men
supporting each other that is so
positive how dare people speak against
that without even understanding what it
is it really it angers me because I see
again on a daily basis within my
interaction with my Warren brothers
everyone is supporting each other in
such a healthy positive way
to try and claim that the war room is
somehow negative or takes messages
negative people don't know what they're
talking about it's as simple as that
they really have no idea what they're
judging well and a lot of these reaction
channels it's like they don't go into
things in good faith and I feel like
that's something we've really lost as a
society and Tate's brought that to the
Forefront because you know he
this is something that's meant to be
positive but these reaction channels are
trying to spin the worm as like a
pyramid scheme like a Ponzi scheme where
it's like I don't know how that would
work yeah I don't know but it's like
they go into things in bad faith like
looking to fit their agenda and they're
overall they're just negative people
they're not positive people
yeah try and again look at the
credibility of the source how are their
belief systems working out for them if
they're deeply unhappy they have
terrible relationships with other people
they don't don't have you know haven't
built businesses that employ people
around the world why would you listen to
their opinions of their advice you know
their own belief systems are failing
them I believe we're at 28. I maintain
the trust of my brothers through
um relevant or reverent silence
regarding our most sacred shared
experiences I believe in honoring my
ancestors and living in a way that would
make the most proud of me today
I reserve the right to administer
difficult Rites of Passage for our young
men to allow them to earn the rank of
manhood
go ahead I mean I mean back in the day
again apologies back in the day cultures
would have some sort of ritual where
you'd become a man all right now you're
13. go out and you have to kill a
certain wildebeest or you have to go and
you know live without food for 10 days
there'll be some kind of rite of passage
men have forgotten that nowadays and to
to drill things into the other than
conscious mind ceremonies and symbols
all these things are very powerful men
used to go through a ceremony surrounded
by other men where they would prove
themselves worthy of being a man and
then there'd be a mindset shift on a
deep level and right now I'm a man I
have responsibilities I'm not a kid
anymore because we don't have that sort
of thing in the west we have a bunch of
grown-up children most men nowadays
they've never been through that switch
so they're still children they're
chasing dopamine they're chasing you
know things that are flashy or feel good
Hedonism nowadays there is no rite of
passage and that's where Tate's war room
that puts men through very challenging X
exercises like the test in Romania where
men got into the cage and fought on very
short notice those sorts of things are
transformational the war room and Tates
messaging and Tates tests that he put
men's he puts men through genuinely
changes lives in a way that Society
needs all the way all these feminists
and haters out there saying where all
the good men gone Tate is creating those
good men
so if anything people should be
appreciating tape not hating on him
oh yeah and they tried to spin that I
saw that clip of the the fight I didn't
really know what it was to be honest but
they were trying to spin that as like
some negative that Tate was like going
into the pyramid scheme thing I'm like
what are these people talking about it's
all just ridiculous and the funny thing
for me I mean there's two different
products there's the real world which is
50 a month if you want to claim that
it's some sort of scam guess what pay 50
have a look it's not hiding
and again the amount of positive uh
life-changing results that that guys are
getting and guys and girls are getting
in there it's so positive and it's out
there journalists could look and see all
of the verified I'm making this money
I've learned these lessons you have tens
of thousands of people around the world
who are told all right get off your
computer do some push-ups drink some
water get back on your computer like
it's overwhelming and healthy not just
in money making but mindset and is it
you know it's a real sense of community
in there then there's the other product
which is the War Room uh Vice tried to
paint that is somehow negative
the worm has changed so many men's lives
for the better we've had men come in who
were depressed post-divorce or who are
struggling to find meaning in life a lot
of men had said I was lonely Before the
War Room now I have brothers around me
who are supporting me it's such a
positive thing the war in terms of men's
mental health and development if it
wasn't Tate then I think you know the
system would love the war because it's
it's helping men and Men's Health and
it's encouraging them to become better
leaders of their family better
contributors to their society so it's
all incredibly positive
sorry that I spout so much I'm not
trying to be a salesperson I just I
strongly believe in this and I'm sick of
it getting trashed I have no idea what
we're talking about no I mean that's why
I wanted to go through these as I wanted
to give you the opportunity so interrupt
as much as you want whenever you have
something don't
um 31 I affirm the importance and need
for Travel and Adventure as men
I seek to help men overcome poor mental
health through embracing hard work
physical improvements and shared
masculine Brotherhood
thousands and dozens of people have
written to Tate and said your message
has saved my life again we've had people
write and say I literally had a gun in
my mouth I was prepared to kill myself I
found the tape message I'm now in the
gym I'm now living a disciplined life I
now have better relationships with
people around me Tate's message is so
positive in a world where there aren't
many positive role models or
motivational speakers for men's mental
health he has literally saved lives so
to the people who say that Tate's
messages are somehow negative have a
little deeper look into what he's
putting out into the world
I reserve the right to make the best
choices I can at the time to protect my
self-respect and mental health
I do good in the world and seek to help
those less fortunate than myself
I actually I wanted to speak to one
thing about Tate so um a lot of people
don't know I was supposed to come to
Dubai for That interview and I ended up
I mean you know this but I ended up
having
um
my passport like I didn't realize that
I'm an American I'm spoiled I was like
they won't let me in the country because
my passport expires within six months
what is this I know I'm American what's
what is this yeah I'm like I'm American
what I couldn't believe it I was like
this has never happened to me in my life
I've never been denied entry anyways so
so Tate actually went out of his way he
paid to fly out here and and came on my
show he didn't have to do that I I
wasn't that big of a YouTuber at the
time and typeflies private for the most
part so it's not a small sum of money
yeah yeah he liked your your promotion
of Traditional Values and he wanted to
to meet you and speak to you like that
he's he's the type of guy where if he
feels somebody is putting a positive
message out into the world and he can
somehow support that then he'll jump on
a private gym and spend whatever the
amount of money is to come over and do
that yeah and working with a lot of
YouTubers
um that's not common like it's not
common for them to be so willing to come
out fly themselves out and you know go
out of his way and a lot of times with
YouTubers they you know you do work with
them and they make a hit piece on you
later and so it just yeah it just speaks
to like it like that was really kind of
him he didn't have to do that but
they're trying to paint him as this
misogynist and they're trying to get me
to say things that like that he did
things he didn't do
exactly well look if
when he comes out I know that he's going
to be very grateful for those who
supported him and like yourself and so I
mean he's going to be pretty sought
after but I know that he'll be sticking
to the people who have supported him
when he couldn't speak for himself so I
can say with confidence that he
definitely want to talk to you again
when he's in a position where he can do
that
yeah no we'll come to Romania whenever
we're ready
um
I do good in the world oh and I've read
that one 35 I believe all men have the
responsibility to lead and guide those
they care for to do greater Health
prosperity and happiness I only I choose
to only interact with those who are
respectful and civil and return to my
own respect and civility
I reserve the freedom to speak and refer
to others as I believe is best and most
truthful
I reserve the right to choose my company
and include only Those whom I believe
are best for my health happiness and
success
what an important message for the the
world not just young men but also young
women I mean I have a daughter I I from
an early age I taught her if you don't
like somebody in your space you have the
right to not have them in your life I I
think a lot of it especially we talk
about women being safe A lot of it comes
down to them feeling empowered enough to
have the assertiveness to say hang on
this is a toxic person I don't want them
in my reality what a positive message to
put out to the world both men and women
that I think's been forgotten nowadays
who else is telling young men and women
today cut out toxic people from your
life you have the right to only
associate with people who are respectful
to you I think that that is the
foundation of having a healthy daily
reality and keeping yourself safe as
well if you want to talk about you know
women's safety yeah I know it's just a
horrible message just misogynistic
horrible let me see him let me stand by
that horrible yeah that's what they'll
do to me
because you know the ever since he's
come on my show they do the same thing
with the clips to like paint me in a
certain way and or since I got to a
certain level and I'm like
it's like really made me realize what
they were doing to him because I'm like
wait they're doing the same thing
they're clipping things I did not say in
order to make it seem like you said
things you did and then it makes you
crazy you're like I didn't say that like
that's not yeah
it's pretty wild yeah uh 39 I believe I
have an imperative to only spend my time
in a way that I determine is beneficial
uplifting and empowering to myself and
others I choose to only allow myself to
be influenced by those who I believe
have my best interests in mind
and every day I dedicate myself Anew to
create the greatest possible impact on
the world and do the work necessary to
achieve a greater masculine Excellence
across all Realms of human endeavor
and so look at that look at the power in
that last sentence and he lives by it
every day and he doesn't stop Tate
doesn't do weekends Tate doesn't if he's
in the cinema with a group he's on his
phone there's one time I saw tape relax
in five years that was when we're on a
catamaran in Croatia and naturally uh
Tristan and I ambushed him the one time
we saw him sort of half fall asleep
relaxing on the sailboat so he doesn't
stop from the moment he's up in the
morning to the to you know he doesn't
sleep much either it's constant work
he's lifting he's training he's playing
chess his mind is always working this is
a man who lives true to that pursuit of
masculine Excellence across all Realms
of human endeavor every day in five
years of rolling a tape I haven't seen
him take even an hour to relax the
closest thing he has to relaxing is
driving his cars but even then there's
movement you know that there are there
are phone calls there's interaction like
the man never stops working to build a
better life for himself and for his
people isn't that the sort of role model
we want for the Youth of today someone
who's walking the walking is that driven
to become the best person that they can
and have the most positive impact on
society I would have thought that was a
good thing no I think they would prefer
um streamers that are out of shape in an
open relationships
no that's a better that's a better role
model yeah that's so much better yeah
video Gamers yeah just unbelievable
losers
um respectfully sorry I'm trying to I'm
trying to be more feminine okay well
allow me to say it then losers I'll say
it for you that's a traditional gender
roles there it is
um what do you think this says about
cancel culture and the way our society
is moving
I mean it's pretty amazing I was there
with Andrew that when the cancellation
you know Beast woke up and really came
after him and in a matter of days his
Banks were shut down his email service
his website servers his payment
processes and there were coordinated
releases across all of the major
journalistic
Outlets uh media houses with pretty much
the same articles the same talking
points there was this coordinated
essentially attack on tape and even now
I saw that Tristan's Instagram was taken
down he hasn't been charged with
anything he didn't break any terms and
conditions his Instagram was him and
suits and cars and motivational quotes
and historical quotes last time I
checked there's no damage there there's
no danger there but they canceled
Tristan as well these men haven't even
been charged with anything and if they
are charged then they're going to be let
you know they're going to be proven
innocent does the cancer culture unwind
did people admit okay I was wrong and
let's let them continue a normal life as
any person should be able to I and this
is the other thing I thought the left
and those who pushed for cancel culture
Were Meant To Be tolerant I mean one of
the biggest things people are coming
after Tate and we can talk some
specifics without crossing any lines is
oh but he's he's aggressive and he's
some how a rapist or something if you
listen to the audio that was released
about him talking about oh I'm going to
do this to you do that to you that's
Kink talk you know Fifty Shades of Gray
is the most popular book of the last few
decades for a reason we're going to
forget that and forget that women and
men have the right to and often like to
partake in aggressive you know forms of
intimacy
I'm sorry but in my personal experience
it's not the man who wants it hard and
aggressive it's the woman correct me if
I'm wrong and so we're going to somehow
pretend that based on this sort of thing
and private interactions between men and
women being released hate some somehow
some kind of monster and he's pushing
that on people it's it's utter nonsense
well and that girl in that video came
forward and said the exact same thing
right the the blonde chick I thought
oh yeah indeed his his ex came out and
said look I've she said it numerous
times this was a kink that we engaged in
and she said she said in human songs and
also who who has the right to pry into
someone's personal life like that that's
100 Haram if two adults want to partake
in consensual acts of any sort that's up
to them I thought the left was meant to
be tolerant of of different types of
sexual expression so if you want to
identify as a Lamppost and go and you
know sleep with someone of the same
gender that's fine but if we have a
heterosexual relationship that involves
some BDSM type activities 50 Shades of
Gray most popular book of all time it's
not an unusual phenomenon somehow that's
a terrible thing and Tate's a bad guy
it's it's utter nonsense the left are so
hypocritical that's one thing they are
consistent in that they're high levels
of hypocrisy well it's tolerant when it
benefits their narrative they don't care
about what's true they don't they don't
care about the truth they care about
telling the story they want to tell and
painting the picture they want to tell
and I don't know if it's malicious or
they're just so brainwashed they can't
see what's right in front of them but I
don't know how you see videos of women
luxury shopping
the whole car was full of bags from
Gucci and LV like it's again sign me up
what what is this put an application on
the website for a Tates um what do they
say Harem is that the right word oh yeah
exactly again Tate's main challenge is
getting women away from him that's not
trying to keep them but to your point
the people who are coming after him are
they doing it maliciously or are they
just brainwashed I don't think they're
doing it maliciously one example being
the device guys all of the guys I mean
look they fit the profile they're skinny
they're effeminate they're you know a
bit shy they they talk about their
relationships with women in a way that
shows clearly you know the women wearing
a pants so everyone everyone's
unfulfilled in their relationships man
and woman
I don't think they're consciously
thinking hey I want to bring down tape
by telling lies I think they've been so
well programmed they actually believe in
all this effeminate programming this soy
culture even though they're deeply
unhappy people they still have bought
into those belief systems and they're
trying to push that on the world because
they have ego identity these are my
belief systems so they must be right
they say hang on you're a deeply
unfulfilled person subscribing to this
religion of wokism why do you think it's
a good thing they can't do those those
you know that mental maths in their head
it's funny to see
it's always the betas
I had to laugh there was because Vice
was really trying to get as much press
out of it to take things they could a
few months after the release there was a
three-person panel with the two Vice
guys who were there at the test and
another Vice guy sitting talking about
it all three of them couldn't bench a
third of their body weight
they all had that that poor posture that
sort of sloping forward they they all
had the same exact sort of effeminate
and slightly uncomfortable with life
Vibes why are you judging someone who's
masculine and capable and and
inspirational when you yourself are
clearly living a very unfulfilling
existence it's hilarious to see if you
look it up you will laugh at how clearly
the three Vice people are exactly the
same you know type of man it's it's
comical I actually laughed out loud
watching that interview well I genuinely
think like to them it seems so crazy
that like women would want that like
they've been lied to about what women
want because they've been told to put
women on a pedestal women want to be
respected women want like and not to not
to don't don't me like that I know
what they're gonna do
they're always
um like they're told that like one thing
about women and when Tate says the
opposite when he says you know women
like a strong masculine leader they want
to submit to Authority uh they just
can't believe it so they think that the
women are like secretly unhappy
interesting but can't they figure out
that the programming that they're
adhering to does not result in a
fulfilling day-to-day reality like if
you do the right thing for this
narrative you're not going to be happy
as a man and your woman's not going to
be happy as a woman because you're not
taking care of her you're not being a
man like why can't they figure out that
this religion of wokism results in
people being unhappy in in breaking up
traditional family Dynamics how how
would you how would you know you're
unhappy if you've never lived that life
interesting like how would they how
would they know I mean I can assume I
can assume that having beautiful women
around you all the time would lead to
happiness you know being rich accessible
yeah I can I can imagine but it's like I
I feel like those guys don't even
realize it in a way because they've
never lived that life and so it's just
so important yeah it's my guess anyways
and so they have to say that tights cars
are hide even though there's tight
written on the seats they have to say
that the women are somehow coerced even
though they're devoted and loyal and
happy so yeah it's all Coke it's all
cope hate always comes from below right
it's it's simple but true
tell me about Tristan we talked so much
about Andrew I want to know what's
Tristan like I've never met him Tristan
is an incredible man he has a very
unique form of intellect because again
I'm the sort of person who likes to
properly understand somebody I used to
be in a line of work where you'd profile
people in a professional manner
Tristan's a very hard guy to fully
understand he is so intelligent he'll
when he drives he doesn't listen to
music he listens to audiobooks he'll be
able to quote direct you know statistics
from a battle in the 1600s and who the
general was did he from an audiobook he
listened to six months ago he can hear
things once and then refer to it with
real specificity you know a year later
it's it's incredible and his his
insights into The Human Condition his
analysis of of society it's very
different it's different to Andrew he's
a very unique intelligence and I really
hope he puts it out you know in the
world more because people don't
understand behind that you know Big
Frame and the traditionally very good
looking man and the nice suits nice cast
is actually a deeply intelligent and
insightful man like Tristan's something
special he is built different and I look
forward to him being even more vocal
when he comes out because people don't
realize how much value he has to bring
uh especially to to role modeling into
motivating uh young men around the world
incredible guy genuinely a very rare
intellect and very kind-hearted as well
he's one of the most giving men I've
ever seen he's genuinely a positive and
good-hearted person and you want to talk
about a brother you can rely on
there isn't much that man wouldn't do to
protect his people fiercely protective
fiercely he is that old-school patriarch
who takes care of his people and he's
very proud about the way he he's put in
the work to be able to do that so I have
huge respect for that man and I look
forward to him being more vocal when
he's out so that the world can realize
how much positivity and value he has to
bring in his messaging as well
what's their relationship like
oh it's man it's amazing so first of all
they live together all the time and I
saw there was a news article that tried
to say that oh it's very unhealthy or
the the article said that somehow
Tristan is under the influence of Andrew
and it's toxic I'm sorry what Tristan
isn't under the influence of anybody if
you know Tristan Tristan's Tristan he
has very strong frame he makes his own
decisions in life they embody true
Brotherhood they would immediately die
for each other without question they are
one team throughout everything in life
their loyalty is absolutely unbreakable
breakable and and it's never questioned
between them they are what men used to
be you know the brother next to me who I
can trust with anything who I can trust
with my family who I know would have my
back in in a you know violent situation
and I can see why you know the narrative
is against that because that's an exact
role model against the idea of men being
isolated and alone and you know low
testosterone and unfulfilled
they are where they are today in life
because of each other and one of the
things within the war room is we
actually say if you find other men with
similar you know business interests or
or you know who want to train like you
do and build build you know custom-made
reality go and live together
replicate that idea of living with your
brothers and just every day pushing each
other training hustling building
businesses putting in Max effort every
day to attain masculine Excellence
across all Realms of human endeavor
a lot of guys in the warm are doing that
are trying to uh embody that that sense
of Brotherhood and brothers living and
working together it's super positive
their relationship's amazing it's super
positive what would have been funny as
if when they're in I don't know if it
happened but if they were in prison or
when they were being questioned if the
authorities tried to play them off
against each other oh that would have
failed miserably it was never in a
million lifetimes would Andrew or
Tristan ever speak against each other or
snitch on each other their Brotherhood
is so strong it's it's truly a beautiful
thing
what um do you think has been the most
damaging lie that has been spread about
the Tates
that you would like to disprove dispel
that maybe we haven't touched on
foreign
I mean the reason why I'm loud and I've
taken consequences in my personal life
and professional life and so on I'm
completely okay with that Tate is it
both of them they're good-hearted men
they they put forward positive messages
and they continually and consistently
work to make their lives better and
their lives better of all of their
followers
so in what Universe are you going to try
and paint them as Negative they are
overwhelmingly positive influences on
Humanity as a whole when they get out
everyone will see that even more so
that's what most hurts me to see the
system try and somehow paint them as
negative when every day they are putting
in maximum effort to be as positive as
they can for them for the you know their
own skills development the business they
build for their Inner Circle and for all
of their followers Tate is passionate
about improving the lives of his
followers it's what drives him he's got
enough money he's got enough accolades
he wants to have a positive impact on
all of his followers he wants to make
the lives of his followers better so to
somehow say this take to somehow a
negative guy it's just it's it's fantasy
it's not real and that really angers me
to see that that's why I'm here that's
why I'm speaking out
and what can we expect from them in the
future once their name is cleared
okay so from what I understand Tate
wants to get back to living a good life
you know I think three months in a
Romanian cell we'll do that to a man so
he wants to get back to living that
motivational life creating that amazing
content to show people what's positive
what's possible so they go out and work
hard to create their own custom-made
realities uh I I understand the focus is
going to be solely positive so be very
careful about what he says obviously he
doesn't want to be sound minded or have
anything taken out of context and again
Tate's main intent is to use the
influence that he now has which has
grown from this whole arrest and
everything to have a positive impact on
Humanity he says it so many times and so
clearly he wants to use the attention
that he's garnered from the world to
leave a legacy to really be that guy who
encouraged a generation of men to
subscribe to Traditional Values to work
hard to be self-accountable to look
after your people to build positive
relationships that's Tate's main focus
in life which I think is very
commendable
and I know we touched on this a little
earlier but how are they doing
they're good I mean the iron mind is
real it's genuinely real like they
weren't phased by Romanian prison even
though their lifestyle prior was private
jets and super yachts and you know
supercars they definitely were
frustrated that was taking so long but
they cracked on I mean Andrew was was
studying the Quran uh and he was doing
his push-ups Tristan I haven't talked to
as much but he would have had a
similarly disciplined day these guys
will make whatever situation they're in
work for them and they'll still work to
better themselves regardless of where
they are and again that's why they're
such positive role models as you said
most people stuck in that situation you
know detained for months for a crime
they didn't do they lose their mind the
dates are focused on
adhering to the beliefs that they put
forward no matter where you are keep
control of your motions stay stoic and
crack on with life you know do your
push-ups study study your faith it's
it's super positive the way they role
model their behavior through these these
last few challenging months
I've been doing um interviews of men
that were falsely accused of crimes and
I don't know any that didn't have
um any sense of anger towards everything
so it's actually amazing to me that they
are coming out of this they're not
shedding on the legal system they don't
really have anger it seems like even
towards their accusers
um it's actually incredible
yeah so a very high and level sorry
apologies shows a very high level of of
stoicism they understand that people
make false allegations they understand
that you know police forces need to
investigate false allegations and they
know with complete conviction that the
truth will win they'll be freed and
they'll they'll get back to their their
mission which is to leave a positive
impact on Humanity to motivate millions
of people to become the best versions of
themselves so yeah I mean it would have
been frustrating for sure and and we've
talked to that but they did they didn't
lose sight of their goal they didn't
they didn't drop off and think oh I'm
just going to sit here and feel upset
and no they don't have anger I haven't
seen any anger in either of them they
understand that these things can happen
and they understand they've got a job to
do Tate's first uh message when he when
he got out uh within the real world uh
which is you know his platform where he
is actually quite active for those who
do want to see Tate chatting and
interact with him then he's inside his
his platform the war the real world and
then in the war room is where he's going
active but his first comments was let's
get back to work the first thing that he
said because that's that he's that guy
yes bad things happen you know feeling
emotions about it won't help there's
work to do let's get back to work that's
what he's about
well thank you so much um is there
anything that you wanted to cover talk
about that we didn't go through
I think it's been a great show thank you
I really appreciate the opportunity and
I love that you spoke through the tenets
of Tate I think it'd be great for more
people in the world to be aware of that
um I will I will put a final pitch in
for the war room because it's something
I very strongly believe in if people
want to message me on Instagram I'll
reply I won't reply instantly but I will
reply I'm trying to respond to everyone
as much as I can the war room is an
incredibly positive supportive community
of men worldwide who live by the tenants
of Tate who work together to be the best
versions of ourselves to to contribute
the best way we can to our families to
give back to our societies so anyone
who's looking for that Brotherhood and
we have everyone from you know 18 year
olds just starting out in their career
to guys in their 60s you know Venture
capitalists running family offices we
have the full spectrum of man of every
religion of every political leaning
everyone's in there supporting each
other and role modeling positive massive
learning for each other in a world where
there isn't much of that so people who
are looking for that Brotherhood to
really Inspire them and support them in
getting the most out of life the war
room is real so any questions you have
message me on Instagram I will endeavor
to respond I very strongly am grateful
for what the worm has given me and I'd
be honored to help other men who are
looking for that Brotherhood which is
hard to find in today's world to come
into the war room so I'll try and
respond to wherever I can that's final
message from me well thank you so much
um I think it's great what you guys are
doing it's actually been really
um inspirational to see his rise and I'm
sure he's going to overcome this too so
I'm excited to see the Tate's name
cleared in the next couple of months and
all of the reaction channels
humbly admitting that they were wrong
I'm sure they'll graciously do that not
gonna name names
it will be satisfying when they're out
and I very much look forward to Future
collaboration with you I know that Tate
strongly respects the fact that you are
promoting Traditional Values and that
leads to a lot of heat being thrown at
you so yeah much respect to you and the
work you've done I've always I mean I
don't watch YouTube much but if I do you
know I'll see your content I really
enjoy it and it takes courage to do what
you're doing I'm sure you've had all
sorts of junk thrown at you so yeah much
respect to you for standing up for what
you know is is real and important in
this life not many people do that
thank you so much um guys make sure you
go sign up um to you said is it the
warroom.com
um I'm not actually sure what the
website is
where you can find a link to the War
Room okay and also uh you can message me
with any questions that you have on
Instagram one of the two that that's how
you can get into the War Room okay guys
um like the video on your way out um
sign up for the War Room subscribe to
the channel and I will talk to you next
time